(Clapping)
- All right, y'all,
let's dive into the world of social media
with something extra fun.
This is what I'm liking.
Parents - some of the best moments are
when you catch your child
being totally themselves.
And they have no idea you're watching.
It's awesome.
Case In point a mom in Ohio
took this amazing video
of her 12 year old son
just getting down y'all
while doing laundry.
It's amazing.
Watch.
(laughing)
- You weirdo.
(Mom laughs)
- Now.
- Okay.
- We didn't.
You need to watch the whole video.
He is my new favorite
person on planet earth.
The whole video will
bring you so much joy.
Can we talk about, though,
how lucky the mom is
That her son's even doing laundry.
(audience cheers)
That's amazing.
He looks happy doing it.
We'll ask her a tip on that.
So Christina and her son, Shane
are on the line right now.
What's up?
- Hey, Kelly!
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
Shane. I'm gonna get to cuz
I love you, but Christina
I'm gonna start with you.
I'm speaking for every mom.
What is your secret in getting
your child to do laundry?
- Well, the secret is
Shane has a cell phone
and he is very motivated to
do his laundry and things are
on the house because if not,
he gets his phone taken away.
Oh. So that's like the big key
is he has to do his laundry
in order to keep his phone.
So, but he's a pretty good kid anyway.
So even if he didn't have a cell phone
he'd still be doing his laundry.
For sure.
So that's our
- I love that.
So Shane
everybody is dying to know
what were you jamming out to, my man?
- I was listening to Erica Banks.
I just kind of felt in the moment...
- It was "Buss it" by Erica Banks.
- Yeah it was "Buss it" by Erica banks.
I just kind of...
- [Kelly] Look at those hips.
- [Shane] Cause in the
moment I felt like myself,
I, when she told me
that she posted the video
on TikTok, I was like, okay.
And I didn't think there
was much gonna happen.
I just thought there
would be a couple likes
and maybe a couple views, but ummm...
- [Mom] it just blew up.
I mean overnight.
I mean, it was like,
there was like a thousand
likes a minute.
We did not expect, especially
from small town, Hicksville
Ohio, we just were not expecting it.
And Shane used to dance
like that all the time when
he was younger.
And then he hit like a
certain age where he just
he didn't do it anymore.
Cuz it was too cool, too cool.
So it was nice to see it cuz
everyone in the comments were
like, how did you get
him to do his laundry?
And how are you not busting out laughing?
It's it was more like a joy
moment for me because when
he was younger, he did that
all the time and it was more
like seeing a little bit
of his childhood back,
back into our lives.
It was nice.
- Well, and I gotta tell you Shane
the best part is that we
are all you, we all do that.
Just not everyone's videoing us.
So like that's why it's
so relatable and we all
love it so much.
You got some moves, man.
You could shake those hips, boy.
Thank you so much, Shane.
Thank you Christine.
I'm liking y'all's post right now.
(ding)
All that's not all our season long partner
Pilot pen makers of G2.
The go to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show.
Wanna honor ultimate
overachievers and dancers
just like you.
So they're gonna be
writing you a check for
a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers)
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh my God.
- I'm just saying it was
it's you can make a lot
of videos with that dancing in it.
Thank you all so much.
I so enjoyed it, Shane.